tend to go by the title uh God logic.
>> My name is Avery, bro.
>> What? Oh, Avery. Yeah. So, hello Mr.
Avery.
>> So, today
>> nice to meet you too. So, the the topic
of of today's uh discussion that you
have already said is did Jesus come for
all of mankind?
>> And I will concede that now I'm not the
Bible. I'm not a biblical scholar. I
don't know the Bible very well. It's not
my book, right? It's not my book. So I
don't know it that well
>> but from what I have read of the Bible I
will concede that from a biblical
understanding
uh of Christianity then Jesus was sent
for the whole world we concede that
>> the
>> that's awesome are you are you are you a
Shia
>> no I'm not a Shia I am
>> yes I'm upon alhamdulillah
>> okay awesome keep going I'm listening
>> so the the disagreement which is really
kind
unreconcilable between us and you is
that we just we don't believe in the
authenticity of the Bible. We have good
evidence to not accept the authenticity
of the Bible. So what the Bible says
doesn't really matter to us. Even if the
Bible said Jesus is God, it wouldn't
really matter all that much to us
because we don't believe in the B. It's
not our book. Kind of like you don't
care what the Book of Mormon says, we
don't really care what the Bible says.
You don't care what the Apocryphal
Gospels say. We don't care what the
Bible says. Ali, if you don't mind me
asking, how old are you, my brother?
>> I'm 18.
>> You're 18?
>> Yeah.
>> You're 18 years old, and you have in the
first two minutes of us meeting, have
been more honest with me, um, with the
Muslim stance, more than hundreds of
Muslims that I've spoken to, much older
than you.
>> So, first I want to say thank you
because you're right.
>> Muslims don't believe in the Bible. So
it doesn't matter what it says. They're
not going to you're not going to believe
it anyway. You don't care. You don't
believe it.
>> Right? So when Muslims try to challenge
us to say, "Where is Jesus in the God in
the Bible?" or "Where in the Bible does
it say this?" And we show it and like
why what does it matter to you? It
doesn't matter because it now it now
goes from yes, it says this to well, I
don't believe in this anyway. It's not
authentic.
>> Let's just be real with it,
>> right? Yeah, we just be real. Of course,
now there are kind of nuances to it. I
don't think especially when it comes
down to the Old Testament. I don't think
I think it's pretty clear that the
doctrine of the Trinity is not uh in the
Old Testament, but that's not the
subject. I don't want to derail your
stream.
>> Um I also don't feel like the doctrine
of the Trinity is really very well
established in the New Testament. You
could say that the New Testament says
Jesus is God,
>> but Jesus being God is not the Trinity.
So if the New Testament says Jesus is
God, you know, that doesn't necessarily
mean the But anyways, that's not that's
not the subject of of of your
discussion.
>> Let me ask you, do you do you uh do you
think cuz obviously I you know I I think
that the Trinity is Old Testament and
New Testament, but on the subject you
you like, okay, you know what, you can
concede that biblically Jesus's message
was for all mankind. He was he was for
everyone biblically speaking. You don't
care about what the Bible says. What
about Islamically? Islamically, do you
think that Jesus was only for Israel or
do you think he was he was uh for all
mankind as well?
>> Well, so I I believe there's a bit of
nuance in this. Now, when we're talking
about Islam, I want to be more careful
because of course Islam is my religion
and I don't want to narrate something
false about my own religion,
>> right? This is a major sin in our faith.
But I would say that as for my
understanding the the Islamic position
is pretty clear in Jesus being sent
exclusively to Israel. But this is not
to say right here's the big caveat. He
is sent exclusively for B is
>> but that doesn't mean that pagans or non
say pagans that doesn't mean that
non-Jews couldn't benefit from Jesus's
message.
you know, like in the book of Acts,
right? There's the there's the whole
discussion where James says, you know
what, the Gentiles, they don't have to
uh James reaches an agreement with Paul
where he says, you know, the Gentiles
don't have to be fully under the law.
All that they need to do is not eat meat
sacrificed to idols, not eat blood, and
I forget what the third uh rule is to
the poor. And
>> yeah, whatever the No, a version of the
Nohad covenant. So we believe the the
main part of me Jesus was mainly sent to
many Israel but that doesn't necessarily
mean that everyone else was completely
excluded and that they had nothing to
gain from Jesus. So is your position
that Jesus
he was sent specifically to Israel but
if Gentiles like non-Jews were to let's
say they heard of Jesus and they heard
what he taught that they can also come
into the faith and and um be be part of
the religion and and uh you know come to
the truth of God in that way even though
he wasn't specifically sent to them but
from hearing hearing what he preached,
they can also come into the faith. Is
that is that is that position?
>> Well, kind of not entirely because and
again I I want to be very careful with
what I say. I don't want to say
something false about Islam,
>> but it it could be possible that first
of all, you could always convert to
Judaism and then you could convert to
Judaism and then be a Jewish Christian
that way.
>> Or if you didn't fully convert to
Judaism, you could be a Nohite, right?
Which is what we see today. You know,
some Jews actually practice this where
you can, if you're a gentile who
believes in Rabbi Schneersen to be the
Messiah, you can be a Nohite,
>> which means that you follow just seven
laws. You don't eat, you don't bow down
to idols, you don't eat pork. There's a
few rules. So, you can be a Noite and
follow a very, you could say, a bridged
version of the covenant of Moses.
>> So, what about Jesus, though? Like, can
can a Gentile come into the faith
through the message of Jesus?
>> Well, entirely, right? No one has ever
said that that's not true. A gentile can
always get circumcised and become a Jew
and then be a part of the message of
Jesus. The question is to what extent do
to what extent can non-ircumcised
Gentiles participate in the religion of
Jesus?
>> Yeah.
>> We disagree. This is where we disagree,
right? Because you would say that the
circumcision is completely abregated
when Paul came. Um
>> I would say when Jesus fulfilled the
law,
>> right? When Jesus fulfilled the law, but
then it was announced with Paul. Um
whereas we would say no, circumcision
was never abregated.
>> Well, it actually was with Peter, not
Paul.
>> Oh, sorry. With Peter
>> um at the council of Jerusalem. But
>> right,
>> but so so this is my thing. Can a is in
your position can a gentile who is not
circumcised
can they convert to I guess you know
following Christ?
>> So you're asking could a gentile follow
Christ without getting circumcised?
>> Mhm.
>> Well one of the greatest scholars of
Islam I don't remember who maybe it was
Imi he said you know knowledge begins
when you say I don't know. And I'll just
have to be very frank with you and say I
don't know exactly
to what extent a non-ircumcised Jew or a
non-ircumcised Gentile rather could
participate in the religion of Jesus.
>> But of course my position right the real
point of contention between you and me
is that I do not believe that what I
definitely don't believe here's I'll
phrase it this way. Mhm.
>> What I definitely don't believe is that
you could 100% participate in the
religion without being circumcised.
Definitely not being circumcised would
put you, I guess you could say, a tear
down compared to the circumcised people.
That is where I believe.
>> All right, let's go with that. Where
where how do where are you getting it
from that circumcision is part of the
religion of Jesus?
Well, because uh the father of the Jews,
Abraham, Ibraim, made a covenant with
his descendants that they would maintain
the circumcision.
And um
>> where are you getting that from?
>> Isn't it narrated in the Bible?
>> But you said you don't care about the
Bible,
>> right? Well, it's also in the Quran. The
>> All right. Where is it? Where is it in
the Quran?
>> I don't have that reference off the top
of my head. I I just saw your stream. I
didn't really prepare much in the terms
of notes.
>> Yeah, I know. It's a lot of free free uh
freestyling.
>> Uh I mean as Muslims we do believe it is
clearly narrated in hadith that I can't
show you. It is clearly narrated in
hadith that actually actually no I can't
actually I do know the source. It's not
in the Quran but it is in the S I
believe of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that um that u like that the
Arabs of Muhammad's tribe practiced
circumcision even though they were
pagans. And this was the one vestage
left of the religion of Abraham.
>> Yeah, but where does it say that that's
part of the religion of Abraham?
>> Well, it's in the Sah. As for the Quran,
I don't know, right? I could Google it,
but then it's kind of I feel like it's a
bit dishonest to be googling things mid
mid debate.
>> That's not We're We're not even in the
this whole time. Ali, do you feel like
we've been debating?
>> No, I feel like we've been having a very
pleasant uh
>> We just We're just talking. So, it's
okay to look look stuff up. I do it on
the top all the time. We're not going to
remember everything. Um to my knowledge
I don't think that is it is in the Quran
that it that it shows that circumcision
is a command.
>> Okay, here it is. It is in the Quran
chapter 16 verse 123. Let me
>> and what does it say?
>> Alah 123. Then we reveal to you O
prophet saying follow the faith of
Abraham the upright who was one of the
Okay, so this actually doesn't mention
um this actually doesn't mention
circumcision. Mhm.
>> Um to
>> my to my knowledge, the commandment of
circumcision is not in the Quran.
>> It might not be.
>> Yeah.
>> It might it might not be in the Quran,
but it is definitely in the it is
definitely narrated in hadith that
circumcision is mandatory for men and
then optional for women.
>> Now, but but where does it say that
that's something that's for ma that uh
that God established with Abraham or
even Jesus?
Well, I guess I'll have to Google it.
>> See, I I think this is something that
you would you would need to go to the
Bible for, but
>> Right. And we can't if it's
>> But you can't because you don't you
don't believe in the Bible.
>> Well Well, that's the thing. There's
actually a bit of of nuance to it. The
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam instructed us to we can take
from the Bible uh within a limited
within a limited um we can we can take
from the Bible in a limited way. In fact
many things
>> it's either you can take from the Bible
or you can't man you can't take you
can't take from the Bible parts that you
that that benefit you but then ignore
the parts that I guess will refute you.
You got to it's either you take it or
you don't.
>> Well, I would disagree with that because
you know or I would like you know if you
look at the canonization of the Bible,
right? One of the requirements to
canonize a book into the Bible was is it
is it not is it apostolic, is it
orthodox? So you can see in every
tradition there's a I mean at the end of
the day it's just not a big point of
contention for us like whether or not
circumcision was a part of the religion
of Moses of Abraham
or whether it wasn't it's just not like
it's it's not a core doctrine
>> but it it is it is something important
because you're saying that this
determines whether or not
>> right
>> a non-Jew was able to come into the
religion of Jesus on whether they were
or not. Right.
>> We don't believe we don't believe that
that that
circumcision is necessarily the um
we believe that that Jesus was spent
sent sent specifically to Bani Israel
because this is what the Quran says
>> and then anything else is secondary
whether or not it's the religion of
Moses, religion of Abraham, religion of
this, religion of that. To all of us
this is secondary right because for to
us the same way as Christians you
believe make disciples in all the
nations in the name of father son and
holy spirit you believe this because
it's in your scripture we believe that
Jesus was spent sent specifically to
Israel just as a part of as a core
belief of our scripture.
>> Okay so him being sent to Israel which
this is actually what both of us agree
on. We agree that he was sent primarily
to Israel, but um obviously with the
Bible, it shows that his message was for
all of mankind. Now I I I actually think
that from the Quran, we can establish
that Jesus is also for all mankind, not
just Israel, even though he was
primarily sent there. But the Quran
talks about him as a sign for mankind
and a mercy. Um you know,
>> well that it's okay. So, you want to get
into that, right? Because Islam is
something I know more about than
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let's talk about it.
>> I'm not a spec a very knowledgeable
person. I'm, you know, I'm just going to
be upfront with you. I'm I'm just a lay
man. I just saw your stream on YouTube.
I decided to hop on. I'm not like a
professional debater or anything like
that.
>> Like, like I said, with a person with
your demeanor, we're not even we're
we're just [clears throat] we're just
talking at this point.
>> Um but so yeah, Jesus Jesus was a sign
is a sign for mankind, right? because of
course he's going to see the thing is
you have to read the Quran in the light
of the hadith. You can't just look at
hadith and you can't just look at the
Quran because they they complement each
other.
>> Okay?
>> They they fulfill each other. Sort of
like you can't just read the Old
Testament and just read the New
Testament, right? You need to read them
in light of each other.
>> Mhm.
>> Because if you just read the Old
Testament, you you would think probably
a lot of false things about Jesus and
about Christianity. And then if you read
just the New Testament and without the
Old Testament, you probably think a lot
of very false things about Jesus and so
you need to see them both together. In
the hadith, it's clearly said that
Jesus, the son of Mary, will come a
second time. So then um the second time
Jesus comes, all of mankind will witness
him. But at that point, the law of Jesus
will be abregated by the law of
Muhammad. It's already been abregated.
So when he comes the second time, in a
way you could say, "Yeah, he's coming
for all of mankind, but it's not the
message of Jesus anymore. Jesus is
coming now under the law of Muhammad for
all of man."
>> Well, this is where I would disagree
with that because for example, under the
law of Muhammad, you have the Jiza.
Right.
>> Right.
>> But according to the hadith, when Jesus
comes back, he's going to abolish the
Jizian.
>> Right. So I would say that you he is
bringing his law and it's it's the law
of Muhammad that's being abrogated and
the law of Jesus whatever he brings is
being the established law.
>> What part of the law of Muhammad is
being abregated?
>> The Jiza,
>> right? But the the Muhammad the Jiza is
set with a term of of of expiration. So
it expires when Jesus comes. And the
reason the reason it's expire the reason
that there is no Jiza when comes is
because now the Christians have nothing
to say and the Jews have nothing to say.
So it's either accept Islam or or after
that point. [laughter]
>> But okay, but e even so though um it
it's still an abrogation of Muhammad's
law. It's it's the Messiah now. He's
here. He's setting it up. You know what
I'm saying? And so,
>> right, I can see why you'd say that.
>> Yeah. So, I I would say that it's even
the hadith point to the Messiah being
the final I guess you could say even the
final prophet, the final messenger
because he's the one coming and setting
the last law,
>> right? I mean, I guess it just kind of
gets down to linguistics, like how
you're kind of defining these words. Cuz
I would just say, well, right, when when
there's nothing really new coming. It's
just Muhammad said, right, this we have
this law and it expires at this specific
point in time. And but I can see why
you'd say that. Like you'd say, okay,
this is a new law. I can kind of see
where you're coming from.
>> Yeah. It'll be the same thing with like
like what you think about Muhammad. You
believe that Jesus and his laws that he
came with that was the set law until
Muhammad came and he brought them in.
>> Right. I can see why you'd say that. But
the reason I would I feel with all due
respect I feel like this might be a
little bit intellectually dishonest what
you're saying is that if you ask your
average Christian
uh is Jesus when he comes in his second
coming is he going to walk around the
Cabba? Your average Christian would say
no. Absolutely not. Jesus is not going
to walk around the Cabba.
>> Of course not. When Jesus comes in his
second coming, is he going to kiss the
black stone?
>> Of course not.
>> Right?
>> Your average Christian would not believe
that. In fact, that belief would take
you out of the fold of Christianity.
>> Right?
>> So, so if you look at the Muslim Jesus,
okay, maybe there's this one very slight
detail of the uh
of the of the you could say the covenant
of Muhammad being um abregated. But when
he comes, what he's going to be doing is
way closer to what uh to what Muslims do
than to what Christians imagine he he's
going to do. Cuz we believe Asa is going
to come down. He's going to have kids.
He's just going to be a normal normal
man. He's going to come down. He's going
to have kids. He's going to have a
kingdom. He's going to walk around the
Cabba. He's going to kiss the black
stone. He's gonna drink Zam Zam water.
He's gonna be
>> might even be a polygamist. Who knows?
>> I mean, hard to be love. So look, when
you're saying this and I and I
understand from your perspective as a
Muslim, I understand.
>> Yeah.
>> But the the the point is this. The point
is is that you have Jesus who's coming
and setting the final law and
establishing the kingdom,
>> right?
>> You have Jesus being said to be a sign
and a mercy for mankind. Not when he
returns, but when he was sent the first
time, he was a sign and a mercy for
mankind. Well, but it doesn't make that
specification that he's he's just a sign
for mankind before he gets lifted up to
heaven because right we don't believe he
died. So there's no it's kind of like
>> it says when we sent him we made him a
sign and a mercy for mankind
>> and he's still sent. That's the thing
right from us it's it's different
because we don't believe he ever got
crucified and resurrected. So he's still
sent. He's just not saying you're saying
that he's a sign for mankind after like
>> sign for mankind after. And you could
still say he's a sign for mankind
before, right? Because of the miracle
birth and the miracles that his mother,
>> the blessed uh Mary
>> and and so with that being said, people
non-Jews can look to the sign of Jesus
>> and come to the true religion, right?
They can look as right. Yes, they can.
But the thing is when they look for the
sign of Jesus and come to the true
religion, they're not going to be coming
when they come to follow the true
religion, they're not going to be
following Jesus because his law is
abregated. When they come to follow the
sign of Jesus, they're going to be
following the law of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
>> Okay? And this and this is where we
disagree cuz even in Muhammad's time,
you still have the law of Jesus is still
valid and authoritative, right? What
makes you say that? So like in in in
chapter 5 cere
in verse 47 um really if you it's verse
43 to 48 in context
>> okay
>> Allah is addressing each group he's
addressing the Jews the Christians and
then the um and the Muslims in verse
>> sorry can you tell me the verse uh
chapter 5 verse 43 to 47
>> okay let's pull this up
[snorts] okay we're doing okay we're
doing
this now. Okay.
What about it?
>> All right. So, verse 43 says, "Why do
they come to you for judgment when they
have the Torah in which Allah's
judgments are in even still they turn
away?" Right? They're talking about the
Jews,
>> right?
>> So, this shows that even in Muhammad's
time, the Torah is still valid for the
Jews and authoritative for them.
>> Okay?
Now, and then when you get to verse 44
and 45, it starts talking about um how
he entrusted, you know, the rabbis and
stuff to take care of the Torah and the
Torah was used as a judgment, yada yada.
Um even talks about what law he he he
mentioned. Then 46, he mentions how he
sent Jesus with the NGO confirming the
Torah that came before him.
>> Okay, so here we are on 46.
>> Jesus came to confirm the Torah. Okay,
so we're we're going from 43 to 46.
>> Mhm. 33. Sorry. Okay. 43 44. Okay. Yes.
I've read this passage,
>> right?
>> Um Okay. So, what
>> So, verse 46, you see, and we sent Jesus
um you know, confirming the Torah that
came before him with the gospel, giving
the gospel.
>> He did confirm the Torah.
>> Exactly. Now and then after that verse
47 verse 47 says so let the people of
the gospel let the people of the judge
by what Allah has revealed in it and
whoever does not judge by what Allah has
revealed they are the wrongdoers
>> right and how do you do that
>> by following the gospel
>> well just read the next verse
>> okay and so in the next verse so not
notice this is in Muhammad's time
>> right
>> Jews are to judge by the Torah verse 43
Okay,
>> Christians are to judge by the gospel in
verse 47. Now verse 48.
>> Now Allah's talking to Muhammad and the
Muslims.
>> Okay.
>> And we gave to you, sent down to you the
book.
>> Um as a confirmation book of truth as a
confirmation of that which came before
it,
>> right?
>> And a Muhammian or a trustworthy witness
or whatever uh over it. Right? So judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
to you and do not uh follow their vain
desires.
>> Right. All right. And then it says, and
this is the interesting part, to each of
you, we have prescribed a law. Right?
>> Okay.
>> Right. Verse 38, right in the middle of
the of the verse.
>> To each of you, we prescribed your own
law.
>> This follows.
>> And if Allah had wanted to, if he
willed, he would have made you all one
nation.
>> Right?
>> But that he might test you in what he's
given you. So competing doing good and
then
>> you know you return to him and he'll you
know tell you about what you guys used
to defer about later on when you
returned.
>> So the bottom half of the verse says
that each of you have been prescribed a
law from a law and if he wanted to he
would have made y'all one nation but he
didn't.
>> Yeah he didn't.
>> So each law is still authoritative even
in Muhammad's time for each particular
group.
Okay, I see what you're saying. But um
you know it's you have to understand
some verses where it gets complicated,
right? Some verses are abrogated by
other verses. Some verses are revealed
in Mecca. Some verses are revealed in
Medina. I'm not a scholar of the Quran.
I'm not a scholar of anything.
>> Yeah. Um
uh right. Of course we had the
constitution of Medina where Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam allowed Jews
to ru their communities according to the
Sharia of uh of the Torah or really the
Sharia of the Old Testament and the
Christians. I don't think there were any
Christians in Medina. But so this is
this is making a statement that um
first of all the Torah I guess kind of
have to unpack this bit by bit. So first
of all the Torah is not the Old
Testament, right? We both understand the
Torah is not the Old Testament. These
are two different
>> How do you How do you know that?
>> Because the Torah is the five books of
Moses.
>> That's the Old Testament.
>> No, the Old Testament has way more books
than the five the the book. So you're
saying that the Torah
>> is not the Torah, right? These are the
Tanakh. It doesn't say we have sent down
to you and confirmed the Tanakh. We've
sent down and confirmed the Torah. And
the Torah is
>> which is in the Old Testament. Right.
>> Right. The Torah is a part of the Old
Testament, but it's not the whole Old
Testament.
>> Gotcha.
>> We know what other books the Jews of of
Medina
>> were had in their possession. Yeah,
>> we do know that, you know, it's more
likely than not the Jews and Christians
that did live in the Arabian Peninsula
had um
they had views that according to their
respective orthodoxies were considered
heretical. So, it's likely that there
were a lot of non-trinitarian Christians
living in 7th century Arabia. There were
a lot of Jews.
>> Yeah, there were a lot of Gnostics
around.
>> Yeah, there were a lot of people with
unusual beliefs. Did you know that from
the Islamic view that the Torah and you
know um encapsulated all the Old
Testament like there's an example
there's a hadith where Muhammad asks a
Jew he says um am I in your Torah do you
find me mentioned in your Torah right
>> and they say yes he says where and then
they begin to start they quote Isaiah 42
they start quoting Isaiah
>> okay
>> and so that shows that There is a um a
view that they saw the entire Tanakh as
the Torah. They referred to the Tanakh,
the whole Tanakh as the Torah.
>> Well, I don't know that I don't know
about this hadith. You'd have to show it
to me. I don't know what's I'm not aith
scholar.
>> You know, the hadith it it gets very
hairy because it's there's hadith that
are inauthentic and then and then
because there's so many more hadith,
right? There's so many of them. A lot of
them are translated very poorly, which
makes it harder for non-Arabs like you
and me to uh to discuss.
>> Yeah. Let's see. Let me see if I can try
to find this uh
[gasps]
where people
let me see. Hold on. Let me let me hit
somebody up and see if they have that.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey guys, do you guys have
>> I know what you're talking about though.
You're talking about the hadith of
Abdullahb
who's a rabbi who converted to um
who converted to Islam.
All right, cool.
All right, let me see if um let me see
if my friends if they know it. Okay,
someone said cyber card. Um that's I
think that's a different one. Thank you.
All right, let's see here. Cyber card
2125.
Let's see. All right, cyber card 2125.
I'm put on the screen so that we can all
see it too, just to make sure it's it's
the right one.
>> Yeah, if I could see it, that'd be
>> By the way, guys, as I'm pulling this
up, make sure you guys hit the uh hit
the like button. There's over 2500
people.
Oops.
There's over 200 people watching here on
YouTube. So, everybody, let's make sure
we get the likes up to at least 2500,
guys. If you guys have not hit that like
button, don't out yourselves. You know
what? You know what the deal is. Don't
out yourself. All right. All right. 21.
That's 19 21. All right. Here it is.
Okay.
Okay. All right. Let me share this
screen.
>> That's me. [snorts] Here it is. All
right. All right. Cyber card 2125.
I met Abdullah bin Ammer bin Alas and
asked him asked him tell me
>> okay tell me about the description of
Allah's messenger which is mentioned in
the Torah it's funny how they put I old
testament
um he replied yes by Allah he is
described in Torah with some of the
qualities attributed to him in the Quran
as follows prophet We have sent you as a
witness and a giver of glad tidings and
a warner and a guardian to the
illiterate. You are my slave and my
messenger. I have named you um I don't
know that how to what's that word.
>> All right.
You are neither dis courteous, harsh nor
a noise maker in the markets.
>> And you do not do evil to those who do
evil to you. So this is a paraphrase of
Isaiah 42.
>> Agree. This is a but right that's the
key word. This is a paraphrase of a
paraphrase of Isaiah 42.
>> Not it is not what it is not is Isaiah
42 word for word. It is not a direct uh
if you could scroll down.
>> It is a Can we Can we agree that it is a
reference to Isaiah 42?
>> You could it's it's similar to Isaiah
40. It's very literally it's
paraphrasing it,
>> right? It's paraphrasing it.
>> So, it's refer It's referring to Isaiah
42.
>> It doesn't say Isaiah 42 in the text,
right? Again, again, the Jews in 7th
century Arabia used a very different
scripture. They had very different
beliefs than today's Jew.
They didn't have a different scripture.
They have the same scripture that I
have. This is why we can pull this up.
This is why we could see this stuff.
What? What?
What
makes you
>> Yeah, but this has nothing to do with
this right here. Right here we have them
paraphrasing Isaiah 42. Can we agree to
that?
>> Yeah, they're paraphrasing Isaiah 42,
but they're not referencing, right?
They're not referencing the the Old
Testament book of Isaiah verse 42. We
don't know how the Torah of 7th century
or the Old Testament rather of Isaiah 42
was structured.
>> We do. We have even older than the 7th
century of Isaiah 42,
>> right? But we don't have it from that
region. My
>> my friend, let's let's be honest.
>> I'm being honest.
>> When you if we're if we're acknowledging
that it's paraphrasing a Isaiah 42
by default, then it's referencing Isaiah
by paraphrasing it. Can we agree?
>> Can you just give me one second? I'm
sorry. Just give me one second. Making a
diagram for you. So, we have source A.
>> I had high hopes for you.
>> Okay. So, we have source A, right? We
have the original Torah of Moses
and then it gets transmitted orally. It
gets remixed. It gets remixed. Let's
even add another letter. It gets remixed
all the way until E. So then this
statement which is originally in the
Torah of Moses is now actually outside
of the Torah of Moses but within the
same collection. It's now within another
book because we don't believe in
necessarily the authenticity of the book
of Isaiah. So
>> why are these why are they quoting it
saying it's from
>> No, but I'm saying they might be
quoting. Okay, so here's the Torah they
have in seventh century Arabia. Oh, they
might be quoting this phantom this
phantom verse in the Torah. Huh?
>> Yes, there you go. It's a phantom verse
in the It could be a phantom verse in
the Torah,
>> which isn't unusual. It's not It's not a
crazy thing to say.
>> Okay.
>> You know, Christian scholars believe in
a Q gospel for the Testament.
>> No, they don't. It's only theoretical
and
>> they believe in the theoretical
>> and not everybody holds to that. No, it
doesn't. But it's a significant opinion
um within Christians with even
opinion. It's only a theory. It's only a
theory held by others, a few. And they
say it doesn't exist.
>> Of course, it it doesn't exist. But I
mean, if you buy a Catholic study Bible,
it's there. They say, in fact, the
Catholic study Bible is very, very pro.
I don't know if you've read the Catholic
study, but the American made by the
>> This is where um I'm I'mma let it I'mma
let this go here.
>> Okay. Wait, one thing before I go.
>> Bring up the next I'm going bring up the
next
He wasn't being honest with me there.
You disappointed me.
>> Before we wait before we get into I'm
not trying to rehash this point. Just
one I'm moving on to the next guest.
>> Stay away from Mr. Michael Jones. He's
dishonest.
>> Thanks for coming, man.